تستعد مدينه بيت لحم لقداس منتصف الليل
لاحياء ميلاد السيد المسيح عليه السلام
وقد انعكست الحرب في غزه على الاجواء في
بيت لحم حيث تجري دون زينه او شجره
الميلاد وقال بطريرك اللاتين الكاردينال
باتيستا ان المطلوب ليس مجرد وقف اطلاق
النار بل وقف حرب الاباده في غزه يذكر ان
بيت لحم مغلقه ومحاصر بالحواجز كغيرها من
القرى والمدن منذ السابع من
اكتوبر معنا في المتابعه من بيت لحم
مراسله الجزيره جواره البديري اهلا بك
معنا اذا
رسائل واضحه موجهه من الكاردينال باتيستا
تتعلق ب الاحتفال في ظل هذه الحرب التي
سماها
اباده رسائل لم تكن متوقعه لانه عاده
الرسائل تكون من بيت لحم تدعو الى السلام
الى المحبه ولكن رساله البطريرك وهو
الكاردينال باتيستا تحدث بالانجليزيه لبس
الكوفيه الفلسطينيه اكد على وقف انه ليس
هناك مطلب لوقف اطلاق النار ولكن وقف كل
ما يحدث في قطاع غزه عوده الاهالي الى
منازلهم التي لم تعد اصلا موجوده وبالتالي
كان ذلك واضح كرساله موجهه الى العالم
الغربي الذي يتجه في انظار كل هذا العالم
الغربي في هذه الليله الى هنا الى كنيسه
المهد حيث بدا قداس منتصف الليل قبل اقل
من 50 دقيقه عاده ما كانت هذه الساحه عبد
السلام تكون تعج بعشرات الالاف من الحجاج
والزوار الاجانب
والفلسطينيين كما نرى هنا فقط لا يتواجد
الا رجال الامن
الفلسطينيين وعدد من مرافقي البعثات
الدوليه لانه في الداخل داخل الكنيسه في
القداس يشارك عدد من القناصل و السفراء
الاجانب دون تمثيل سياسي بالطبع
والكنيسه دون اجراس دون زينه دون شجره
الميلاد كل شيء هذا العام مختلف تماما ان
تدخل الكشافه بدون ادوات عزف هي دخلت
بشعارات اطفال يحملون اي شعارات تطالب
بوقف حرب الاباده على غزه اعمال فنيه تجسد
الواقع في غزه من خلال رساله السيد المسيح
بانه ولد وفي يوم مولده قام الرومان بقتل
الاف الاطفال والرساله بان كما قتل في ذلك
اليوم ق قبل
20223 عاما اطفال ليحي السيد المسيح عليه
السلام تحت الاستعمار فان الاستعمار بشكله
المختلف يتواجد الان في غزه يعني المجسم
هنا الذي وضعته الفنانه الفلسطينيه رنا
بشاره يجسد السيد المسيح عليه السلام ليله
مولده
وفق التقاليد المسيحيه ولكنه في محمل على
كوفيه وداخل غرفه الخ داج هذه الغرفه التي
كانت اشهر صوره لشكل المجازر والاباده
التي مورست بحق الاطفال الخدج في مستشفيات
قطاع غزه هذا التجسيد لواقع الحرب على غزه
ايضا هنا هذا العمل الفني ايضا الذي كان
اليوم محط انظار الاعلام الغربي وكان
الرساله الاوضح هنا كانت شجره عيد الميلاد
اكثر من 20 قدم بكل الوان تحديدا اللون
الاخضر والاحمر الان نرى لون رمادي في
اشاره ورمزيه بدايه الى ان السيده مريم
العذراء في تجسيده رساله الميلاد بانها
حزينه ككل امهات اطفال غزه تحمل كنف كفن
ايضا المجوس والرعاه بينهم من هو لاجئ
اصبح ونازح وبين من بدل ان يحمل الهدايا
جاء بالاكفان البيضاء ان هذا هذه خريطه
لغزه ان رايناها من السماء تجسد الخريطه
ايضا صاروخ في داخل كنجمه الميلاد اذا كل
ما حدث اليوم كان بالنسبه للاعلام الغربي
جدا مهم لان كل انظار العالم في هذه
الليله وتحديدا الان من داخل كنيسه المهد
عاده ما ينظر العالم
الغربي ويتابع قداس منتصف الليل وبالتالي
اراد المسيحيون اليوم ان يرسلوا رساله الى
العالم بان حرب الاباده في غزه يجب ان
تتوقف ارفعوا الحصار اوقفوا كل ما يحدث
حتى الفلسطينيين فقط شيء اخير ان سمحت لي
عبد السلام يعني ال في عاده ما يصل ليس
فقط الحجاج الاجانب ولكن ايضا الفلسطينيون
من الضفه الغربيه لكن بالطبع من غزه هي
محاصره اصلا منذ 16 عاما ولكن حتى هنا من
داخل الخط الاخضر ومن الضفه الغربيه لم
يصلوا الى بيت لحم لانها محاصره ايضا ككل
مدن وقرى الضفه الغربيه منذ السابع من
اكتوبر اذا ايضا حتى الحصار والامتداد
الاستيطاني كله يعني كل هذه المشاهد تتجسد
منذ السابع من اكتوبر لذلك كانت هذه
الرسائل ترسل هنا من في ليله الميلاد الى
العالم اجمع شكرا جزيلا لك جوار البديري
من بيت
لحم